und das ist heute die Schlagzeile des
Tages die Kommunen können nicht mehr
Bürgermeister schlagen Alarm
CDU-Politiker christian baldorf hat
seinem
Ärger bei die richtigen Fragen Luft
gemacht hören wir doch einmal rein
man muss dieses Asylrecht überdenken das
glaube ich schon und zwar natürlich sehr
human sie müssen am Ende des Tages
schauen dass sie hier keine Anreize
bieten und dann will ich Ihnen einen
Punkt auch noch nennen wieso zahlen wir
denn Gelder an alle diejenigen die
herkommen da würden natural Leistungen
zunächst auch erreichen
Naturalleistung so deutlicher das kaum
ein Politiker je ausgesprochen kein Geld
mehr für Flüchtlinge ist das die Lösung
Hans
ja nicht da ich glaube in dem Fall kann
man das nicht so allgemein sehen aber
ich bin viel eher der Meinung dass der
deutschen Justizministers der gesagt hat
die Einbürgerung die dafür aus der
folgen wenn jemand auch einen Job hat
denn dass wir nur auf die Dauer mit
Leistungen prahlen und alle alle Geld
ausschütten ohne dass die Menschen auch
einfinden in die in die in die Arbeit
das geht auf die Dauer nicht ich glaube
da müssen wir ein bisschen härter werden
das hat nichts zu tun also mit mit
Herzlosigkeit sondern mit Vernunft denn
wir können auf die Dauer diesen Staaten
nicht erhalten wenn wir Millionen
Menschen aufnehmen die ungeregelt zu uns
kommen und die ungeregelt etwas Geld
bekommen dass alle Steuerzahler etwas
kostet ja auch ohne einen bürgerung
bezahlt
das ist richtig deshalb muss man da
besonders vorsichtig sein nicht dass es
geht natürlich nicht auf die Dauer dass
jemand und ich weiß dass aus eigenen
Bekanntenkreis dass jemand der Geld der
bezieht und zwar für Mutter zwei Kinder
und so weiter dann sagt arbeiten gehen
ich weiß nicht ob das sinnvoll ist ja
weil ich bekomme dann weniger als ich
bekomme wenn ich die ganzen die ganzen
fürsorgen und die ganzen Bäckereien
kassiere das geht nicht und da muss man
Grenzen setzen da bin ich der Meinung
dass das überhaupt nicht herzlos ist
sondern dass das auch im Sinne der ist
dies betrifft nämlich damit die auch so
angesehen werden wie sie angesehen
werden wollen jemand der kommt als Gast
und hier Platz finden will und arbeiten
will und auch einen Teil der
Gemeinschaft sein wollen
sie von dem Vorschlag Sachleistung kein
Geld darüber kann man reden aber die
großen Probleme ist andere erstens wird
in Deutschland immer noch nicht
unterschieden zwischen denen die wir
brauchen weil wir Arbeitskräfte
Fachkräfte brauchen einander
und denen die in die Sozialsystem
Migranten pro Jahr qualifizierte ja aber
qualifizierte nicht die die kommen um in
die Sozialsysteme einzufordern wenn die
kommen dann wird man sie ja nicht mehr
los das ist das eigentliche Problem ja
also wenn man es nicht schafft mit den
Abschiebungen wenn Sie schon mal hier
sind so ähnlich hat es glaube ich meine
Frau Merkel gesagt das sind sie halt da
ja dann muss man sie halt auch anständig
behandeln das finde ich schon was aber
nicht geht ist dass das auf Kosten der
deutschen Bevölkerung und zwar auch das
sozial Schwachen passiert wie es
Geschehene sind Lörrach werden
sozialmieter
entmietet wie man so schön sagt in
Berlin wird ein Altenheim geschlossen
damit der Flüchtlinge einziehen das sind
alles Dinge die die Akzeptanz der
Flüchtlinge in diesem Land
zerstören und das ist überhaupt das
entscheidende dass die Leute hier
willkommen sind und wenn sie gekommen
sind dann müssen wir auch was tun dann
müssen Sie selber für Integration eine
Lösung dafür also wie uns dieser Anrei Z
zum Arbeiten gelingt wie wir schaffen
mehr Flüchtlingen Arbeit zu bringen
naja die dürfen wir zum Teil gar nicht
arbeiten selbst wenn sie es wollten das
ist ein Problem dass man auch nicht ganz
ausblenden darf aber das Problem ist
nicht zu lösen sie müssen weniger Leute
reinlassen sie müssen die wenn Sie sie
nicht wollen schon an den an den Grenzen
müssen Sie die Sache regeln und wenn Sie
hier sind müssen sie die auch abschieben
können da ist das Problem
Einigkeit in der Runde gehen wir mal zu
Bela ja wir sehen hier so ein
klassischen Mangel an politischer
Kommunikation denn wenn du sagst Nena
und einmal müssen wir dir gratulieren
also einmal zu 4bs Bräutigam Bild
Bestseller alte weise Männer freue ich
mich schon auf den Einstieg wo immer das
Land wird aber meine Voraussage ist
unter den Top 10 und jetzt auch wieder
Bild TV willkommen zurück bevor wir uns
ja ich freue mich auch wieder hier zu
sein ganz klar gibt's dafür Sekt heute
oder
Champagner das ist eigentlich ein
bisschen schade aber die Themen sind
auch zu ernst und dementsprechend
bleiben wir bei den Flüchtlingen aber
ich bedanke mich für die Glückwünsche
sehr gern aber noch mal zurück zum Thema
also diese politische Kommunikation die
hier völlig aus dem Ruder gelaufen ist
wenn du sagst Nina 400.000 werden
gebraucht jedes Jahr und das sind ja
offizielle Zahlen jeden Tag ne ich
glaube der Mehrzahl der Bevölkerung sagt
400.000 noch mehr Menschen wo sollen die
denn alle unterkommen die kommunalen
Amtsträger die Bürgermeister die
Landräte sagen wir sind schon voll wir
sind Schulen Turnhallen die überfüllt
sind mit Flüchtlingen und das kommunale
Leben was natürlich darunter echt das
ist eine Wahrheit die kann man auch
nicht weg negieren und sagen das ist
halt mal so sondern die belastet viele
Kommunen die belastet viele Menschen und
die wird ein bisschen negiert dann
gibt's so ein Flüchtlings gibt für ja
das man sich so ein bisschen eine einig
und natürlich hat die CDU gesehen dass
die dieses Thema den Menschen auf den
Nägeln brennt und deswegen veranstalten
die ja mit den einzelnen Leuten aus den
Gemeinden einen eigenen
flüchtlingsgipfel und deswegen gibt es
auch solche Äußerungen aber alle
pauschal der über einen Kampfsystem und
sagen alle Flüchtlinge sind natürlich
jetzt ganz furchtbar das ist es nicht
sie müssen schnell den Arbeit gebracht
werden können das hat der CDU-Politiker
auch gar nicht gesagt er hat nicht
gesagt alle Flüchtlinge sind furchtbar
sondern hat gesagt er schlägt vor
Sachleistung anstatt Geld ja da muss die
Zeit des Flüchtlings da sein aber auch
begrenzt sein und begrenzt sein können
mit auch den Konsequenzen dass wir es
nicht schaffen dann eben zurückgeführt
wird oder zurückgeführt werden kann oder
meinetwegen in eine europäischen
Nachbarstaat aber nicht auf Dauer hier
eben alimentiert wird deswegen hat er
auch gesagt Asylgesetz grundlegend
ändern da sind wir hier alle einer
Meinung da ist natürlich dann die Frage
herrlich warum passiert das denn nicht
also hier ist selten so viel Einigkeit
am Tisch wie jetzt gerade was das Thema
Flüchtlinge betrifft ja das ändert sich
ja gefühlt nichts und was Sie gesagt
haben stimmt ja auch manche warten drei
Jahre auf der Arbeitserlaubnis weil
dahinter eine Ideologie steckt ja wir
sind weltoffen wir sind für alle wir
haben ein großes Herz es wird nicht
rational entschieden es ist
Gesinnungsethik und nicht
Verantwortungsethik wenn ich das mal
sagen darf ja es wird es wird nach einem
Prinzip entschieden das Moral es ist
moralistisch ist wenn ich sagen
moralisch ist auch nicht unmoralisch
aber es ist moralistisch und damit kann
man keine Politik machen Entschuldigung
wir werden noch mehr unter Druck kommen
wenn die Engländer das tatsächlich wahr
machen dass sie jeden der nicht legal
einreißt sofort wieder zurückreißt er
gar nicht die Möglichkeit bekommt mehr
um einen Flüchtlingsstatus anzusuchen
dann würden wir noch mehr unter Druck
kommen weil dann werden die Leute eben
wieder ausweichen von Enger natürlich
mehr nach Deutschland weil das das
beliebteste England wanderungsland ist
und da braucht man wirklich einmal
konkrete politische Ansätze und nicht
nur immer ja wir werden schon irgendwo
schaffen
sie sind in Deutsch aber leben ja in
Österreich ich bin Österreicher und bin
in Deutschland aufgewachsen dann sind
sie beide sind weniger Österreicher aber
wie diskutiert man in Österreich darüber
ich
gute Frage wie man in Österreich
wahrscheinlich eh ähnlich wie hier ich
habe nur bei den ersten Statement immer
härtere Worte gefunden
was mir hier aufgefallen ist eine Runde
weil weil die Frage ist wo wir alle so
einer Meinung sind was ich hier gehört
habe ist wir haben es immer mit Menschen
zu tun als erster Stelle die hierher
kommen und und vielen so Worte wie wenn
sie kommen dann werden wir sie nicht
mehr los oder 400.000 werden gebraucht
ich habe für was werden die gebraucht
werden die missbraucht weil man sie
braucht was für unseren Wohlstand wir
warum weiß ich ich höre hier ja mir
fehlt das ja klar bei mir fehlt hier
zunächst mal dass es sich um Menschen
handelt und diese Menschen kommen aus
Ländern wo es offensichtlich nicht so
schön ist wie bei uns die müssen
flüchten aus welchen Gründen auch immer
und sind mit hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit
traumatisiert und wenn wir uns diese
Menschen ins Land hereinholen und sie
gleich mal in die Arbeit schicken ja ich
weiß es dass meine psychotherapeutischen
Praxis wenn Menschen realisiert sind
verängstigt sind depressiv sind
psychopathologisch auffällig sind dann
brauche ich die nicht gleich in die
Arbeit zu stecken ja und und sie zu
überfordern die werden zuerst mal die
müssen das mal abgeholt werden also wenn
ich die auch ein bisschen Probleme wenn
wir solche Leute die Menschen sind um
Gottes Willen selbstverständlich aber
wenn wir so traumatisierte Personen
anziehen dann wird es ja für uns auch
ein Problem genauso ist es ja genauso
ist es genau das will ich damit sagen
also ich würde sagen wir müssen diese
Menschen zunächst mal menschlich abholen
das heißt
einzelne wahrnehmen ne wir müssen sie
erst einzeln
glaubt er muss arbeiten und kann nicht
immer das ist der da kommt oder welche
Möglichkeiten diese Person überhaupt
mitbringen arbeiten zu können auf jeden
Fall eine Obergrenze weil wenn man
beispielsweise ein Haus nimmt in ein
Haus passen ja auch nicht 100 Leute rein
sondern vielleicht nur zehn Leute sehr
gut leben können das heißt wie wollen
wir schaffen wenn immer mehr Menschen
kommen es wird ja jetzt schon zu wenig
auf den einzelnen geschaut ich habe
meine Kamera im Flüchtlingsheim
gearbeitet da kann ich sagen damit
niemanden geschaut ganz furchtbar also
das heißt genau das meine ich für die
Flüchtlinge besser wenn man sagt es
werden nur so und so viele aufgenommen
aber die werden richtig integriert warum
werden denn nur so wenig dann
aufgenommen Frage aber wenig aber sagen
wir mal jetzt ja zu wenig Geld oder wie
ich meine in den letzten drei Jahren
haben wir doch Geld rausgefert was das
Zeug hält für alles mögliche und jetzt
plötzlich fehlt noch interessant oder
das Paradoxon bisschen zu einfach ich
meine appellieren hier an den
Menschenverstand und wer könnte dem ich
fand das ja nicht anders verstanden
sondern Menschlichkeit wer könnte dem
etwas entgegensetzen wenn wir nicht alle
Menschen Feinde sein wollen dass keiner
von uns sein wird fakt ist doch das was
wir alle wissen dass die Kommunen echt
sind unter den Belastungen man muss es
einfach so nennen von Menschen die zu
uns gekommen sind wo die Kommunen sich
aber allein gelassen fühlen also die
verschiedenen Landkreise die Städte die
kein Platz haben wo die Schulen überqu
sie keine Lehrkräfte haben für diese
Menschen die
unentwegt und immer weiter zu uns kommt
wo es keinen stoppen gibt und auch keine
Integration in dem Maße wie wir es
eigentlich haben müssten kein
Deutschland in dem Maße deswegen sind
wir doch nicht Menschenfeinde wenn wir
einfach darauf hinweisen es ist diese
Zustände gibt und uns mit den Fragen
beschäftigen was kann man tun um diesen
Zustand zu ändern und sie sagen lasst
ein fröhlich weil das Geld ist ja da
muss auch dafür ausgegeben es kann
Methoden mit diesem Problem aber nicht
gesagt dass hier Menschen fahren sind
jetzt gesagt das allererste was ich hier
für mich als Mensch verlange ist
Menschlichkeit diesen diesen
Einwanderern und Flüchtlingen gegenüber
und das ist kurzfristig und ja gedacht
zu sagen wir holen Sie jetzt rein und
geben Ihnen schnell Arbeit für mich ist
es ein nachhaltiges Thema die werden
eben nicht gehen ja sondern sie werden
sich hier integrieren was ich hoffe Sie
werden sich an die Kultur anpassen sie
werden hier leben sie werden hier
Familie gründen und das heißt wir werden
nachhaltig für diese Menschen sorgen
müssen dass wir nicht eine weiterhin
Angst erkannte Gesellschaft haben weil
genau das ist ja gerade das große Thema
und das Problem in dem wir uns befinden
wir haben wahnsinnig viel kranke
Menschen in diesem Land aber das sind
Inländer das sind nicht Ausländer aber
die Angst Erkrankung das kann ja auch in
Grund dafür sein dass wir zu viele neue
Bürger aufnehmen oder Flüchtlinge
aufnehmen auch das kann zu Angst
Erkrankungen führen wenn Sie heute auf
einem Bahnhof etwa in Köln wo ich zu
Hause bin da denken Sie nicht das in
Deutschland sind ja das ist jetzt nichts
Böses man darf das ja auch nicht
aussprechen ist mir egal AFD oder sonst
irgendwas
auszusprechen weil ich es weiß von
meinem Bekannten und Freunden und freien
von Frauen ja die sagen ja das geht so
nicht also man darf die Angst den nicht
immer sehen nur auf der einen Seite
einwandererseite auch die
von denen die von der eingewanderung
betroffen sind da muss man das auch
sehen absolut sehe ich auch aber dann
wie gesagt dann können wir uns bitte um
diese Menschen die hier in unser Land
kommen um deren Angst Probleme damit wir
selber keine Angst haben müssen
irgendwann mal das ist die messen wir
uns darauf dass die Integration besser
werden muss in diesem Land
abgezockt oder reingelegt
das ist also eine Verzehnfachung jetzt
melden unsere Reporter kümmern sich um
Ihren Fall
kämpft für Sie